the Senate Intelligence Committee
Committee is hearing testimony this
morning on threats to America from all
around the world
senators are questioning the Director of
National Intelligence and the Chiefs of
the CIA the National Security Agency and
the FBI they are also expected to ask
about FBI tactics in the Russia
investigation former CIA director Leon
Panetta also served as Secretary of
Defense in the Obama administration and
chief of staff for President Bill
Clinton he's in Washington this morning
Secretary Panetta good to see you thank
you so much for joining us nice to be
with you you have had such an
interesting perspective in your
government profession holding so many
different roles so I want to ask you in
particular about how the nation's top
secrets are handled inside this White
House given the recent allegations
against the former staff secretary Rob
Porter is it unusual to have someone who
doesn't have a full clearance handling
this type of intelligence it's unusual
this far into a new administration it's
over a year that this administration has
been in office and normally because of
the priority of getting security
clearances to those that have to be
involved with top secret and highly
classified information it usually is a
priority that's focused on so I think
the fact that there are still a number
of individuals that don't have a full
security clearance is a real problem and
hopefully it'll be dealt with but it
creates a risk because individuals are
going to see highly classified
information coming across their desk and
it creates a risk that they could see
that and I want to ask you about the
role of chief of staff because you have
been a White House chief of staff it's
our understanding CBS News is reporting
that the FBI finished their background
check on Rob Porter in the summer and
gave that information to the White House
and one official is saying that Rob
Porter's interim clearance would have
expired last month and so says is the
fact that chief of staff Kelly a former
military officer and former Secretary of
Homeland Security would not have seen
this as
problem is staggering he would know
better than anyone that managing highly
restricted information is essential to
American national security every person
who has access the most sensitive pieces
of intelligence must be supremely
trustworthy do you think that this White
House is allowing someone without the
proper clearance to handle some of the
nation's top secrets and is Kelly
culpable well somebody's dropping the
ball that's for sure because these these
investigations should have been
completed and you know John Kelly is a
Marine general he understands the
importance of getting these clearances
done I I can't believe that more
pressure has not been brought on those
involved to complete this and try to get
everyone cleared so that they can get on
with the business of the country so I I
think you know if you you're looking for
where to place blame I think everybody
bears some responsibility here it's not
just the chief of staff it's others who
should be asking where is my security
clearance and shouldn't it be completed
rather than standing back and allowing
this interim security clearance to take
effect that just is a bad way to do
business you had told NPR in the past
and you were worried about chief of
staff Kelly because he's not a
politician that he is a marine with a
military background what were you
concerned about well you know John is
somebody who is first and foremost a
marine he's very dedicated to the
country I'm sure he's dedicated to
whoever is commander-in-chief but John
is not a politician and probably
probably doesn't want to be a politician
why is it important to be a politician
in this particular case because you know
a chief of staff has to be careful about
what he says and how he says it because
the most important thing is that the
chief of staff should not become the
headline chief of staff should frankly
stay in the background and recognize
the land mines are in terms of public
policy and also press policy so that's
that's just something hopefully John can
learn secretary job secretary panetta
the New York Times reports at 30 there's
an in a 34 percent turnover rate in the
white house Rob Porter's one of those
that's been out the door given your
experience across all of government how
does an administration work when you
have that kind of turnover when does the
team get on the field and operate as one
voice if everybody is turning over that
fast you you can't you can't feel the
football team if 30% of the players are
not there that's just a reality and the
same thing is true for the White House
and for the administration for that
matter I think it's really important
that they fill those jobs that involve
the kind of responsibility that an
administration has to exert if they're
going to do the business of the country
how can you do the business of the
country if you don't have key people in
place it's just it just is not going to
happen one or two people can't cover all
of those bases that's just a reality I I
think it's incumbent upon the
administration and coming upon the
personnel people there to get these jobs
filled so that they can do the business
of the country all right all right Leon
Panetta we'll have to leave it there
thank you very much